macaulay culkin and brenda song are
engaged according to multiple reports
the home alone actor put a ring on it
here's the doll face star out in beverly
hills on monday rocking a huge diamond
ring on her left finger check out that
massive sparkler
the engagement comes less than a year
after the couple welcomed a baby boy
named dakota in april i'm really i'm so
grateful according to esquire dakota's
song culkin was named in honor of the 41
year old actor's sister who died in 2008
and even though the very private couple
has kept their relationship mostly under
wraps mccully told joe rogan in 2018
that he planned on having kids with the
former disney star do you plan on making
people
oh yeah yeah no i want i want i'm gonna
make some babies you know all that kind
of stuff so yeah this one so this one's
a good one so you know like i'm probably
gonna put some babies in here like in a
little bit
you know i mean we're definitely been
practicing but uh yeah yeah fast forward
to 2021 and baby dakota arrived just
weeks after brenda's suite life of zach
and cody co-star ashley tisdale had a
baby too don't bother darlings i own the
place i want it
i got the candy counter girl to bring us
some snacks please
thank you for introducing me but i do
have an actual name
it's maddie what goes through your mind
when you think about how you were kids
together acting on the same show and now
you both have kids yeah i mean
it's that is that is crazy um it is so
weird i feel like it just shows what
stage of life we're in she um i think is
like obviously
killing it as a new mom as well but uh
but yeah it is just so
so crazy
macaulay and brenda first met on the set
of seth green's 2019 movie changeland
you guys
you guys i'm up next okay for me for me
okay cool shut up
mr pal
it's fun
how was it working with mr mccully
culkin wonderful seth green is a
wonderful friend of mine it's his first
project he directed wrote and starred in
he did everything and he brought
basically all of his best friends to
thailand which is you know where i'm
from and i'd never been so we spent
seven weeks in thailand with our best
friends and made an amazing movie that
i'm excited to share with everyone and
since they're both former child stars
mccully most known for home alone
and brenda for her work on the disney
channel
this is a team secret
you get to be our
alternate is that good good
it's great
it means that if somebody else can't
bowl you get to be our secret weapon oh
oh can i still wear my cheerleading
outfit you can wear whatever you want
jamie
[Music]
the actress revealed what it's like to
share that same special bond i mean i
think that's one thing that you know
it's almost like child actors we don't
get to talk about you just look each
other in the eye and you nod and we know
congratulations to the happy couple on
their engagement
[Music]